[Music]
This is a story with Haruna Kimi
We grew up in a world that wouldn't let us dream even though we wanted to dream.
[Music]
But
somewhere, somewhere, there was an
exciting world that no one knew about.  Nagi, a
high school student who loves time fantasy, meets a
fallen dragon named Nori who came from another world, Oupananta.The
death of the time world begins from here.His
mission is the real world.  Find Britain, who was blown away, and
save the world.The
bee
opens and the world
begins to devour the world.There must be an imaginary here.You're the
one who created Woopa Nanta.You ca
n't do anything, you're a useless
time world.  I want to save the world, but I
don't want something so sad to happen.When I'm with Time, I feel
like something can change.
Because of this, the dragon Nori
won't give up.This is two worlds, which one to protect.Imagination opens the
door to the world.
[Music]The
Wonder Hatch opens to the sky and the island of yellowtail.DET